Je les remarque partout, dans chaque chose.
Ma famille se moque de moi
car j'aime utiliser des couleurs avec des noms élusifs
comme céladon...
(Rires)
écru...
carmin.
Si vous ne l'avez pas remarqué, je suis noire, merci --
(Rires)
et en grandissant, comme moi, dans une ville ségréguée,
comme Chicago,
vous êtes conditionné pour croire
que la couleur et la race ne peuvent jamais être séparées.
Il se passe rarement une journée
sans que quelqu'un ne vous rappelle votre couleur.
Le racisme est la teinte éclatante de ma ville.
Nous sommes tous d'accord que la race est une construction sociale
mais il est difficile de le voir dans notre quotidien.
Son omniprésence est partout.
Les quartiers où j'ai grandi
étaient emplis d'une beauté culturellement codifiée.
Les principales artères commerciales
étaient bordées de devantures peintes en couleurs vives
qui rivalisaient pour les dollars des consommateurs noirs.
Les mélanges visuels créés par les épiceries, les centres de beauté,
les bureaux de change
sont le lieu où j'ai, par inadvertance, appris les principes fondamentaux
de ce que j'apprendrai plus tard être la théorie des couleurs.
Je me souviens d'avoir été intimidée par ce terme à l'université --
la théorie des couleurs.
Tous ces vieux gars blancs et étouffants avec leurs traités
et leurs terminologies obscures.
Je maîtrisais chacune de leurs palettes de couleurs et leurs principes associés.
La théorie des couleurs se résume à l'art et la science
d'utiliser les couleurs pour créer des compositions et des espaces.
Ce n'est pas compliqué.
C'était ma bible à l'université.
Josef Albers a émis une théorie sur la couleur rouge
et cela m'a marquée.
Il avance que la couleur iconique d'une canette de Coca-Cola est rouge
et que nous nous accordons tous sur le fait que c'est rouge,
mais les genres de rouge que nous imaginons
sont aussi variés que le nombre de personnes dans cette pièce.
Imaginez cela.
Cette couleur que l'on nous a tous enseignée depuis la maternelle
comme étant primaire --
rouge, jaune, bleu --
n'est pas primaire,
n'est pas irréductible,
n'est pas objective mais subjective.
Quoi ?
(Rires)
Albers appelle cela « relationnel ».
Relationnel.
C'était la première fois
où j'ai été capable de voir mon quartier comme étant un contexte relationnel.
Chaque couleur est affectée par sa voisine.
Chacun est affecté par son voisin.
Dans les années 30,
le gouvernement des États-Unis a créé
l'administration fédérale du logement
qui a créé un ensemble de cartes
utilisant un code couleur pour déterminer quels quartiers
devaient recevoir ou non des prêts fédéraux au logement.
Leur carte de la sécurité résidentielle était sa propre palette de couleurs
et a été plus influente que l'ensemble de toutes ces palettes de couleurs
que j'avais étudiées à l'université.
Les banques ne prêtaient pas aux gens vivant dans des quartiers comme le mien.
Je suis en D86.
Leurs cartographes coloriaient ces cartes
et marquaient cette couleur comme étant « risquée ».
Le rouge était le nouveau noir
et les quartiers noirs étaient colorés.
Le problème persiste aujourd'hui
et nous l'avons vu durant la crise des saisies immobilières.
A Chicago, cela est symbolisé par ces X
qui sont inscrits sur la façade des logements vacants
dans le sud et l'ouest de la ville.
La réalité est que la palette de couleurs de quelqu'un d'autre déterminait
mon existence physique et artistique.
Ridicule.
J'ai décidé de créer ma propre palette de couleurs,
de parler aux gens qui vivent où je vis
et de changer la façon dont les couleurs avaient été définies pour nous.
C'est une palette que je n'ai pas eu à chercher bien loin
ou dans des traités
car je la connaissais déjà.
Quel genre de peintre émerge de cette réalité ?
Quelle est la couleur de l'urbain ?
Quelle est la couleur du ghetto ?
Quelle est la couleur du privilège ?
Quelle est la couleur de ce qui est lié aux gangs ?
Quelle est la couleur de la gentrification ?
Quelle est la couleur de Freddie Gray ?
Quelle est la couleur de Mike Brown ?
J'ai fini par trouver un moyen
de lier ma compréhension racialisée des couleurs
et ma compréhension théorique des couleurs.
J'ai mis au monde mon troisième bébé :
« La théorie de(s) couleur(s) ».
(Rires)
« La théorie de(s) couleur(s) » était un projet artistique de deux ans
où j'ai appliqué ma propre palette de couleurs dans mes quartiers
et à ma façon.
Si j'allais dans la rue
et demandais à 50 personnes le nom de la teinte légèrement verte du cyan,
les gens me regarderaient de travers.
(Rires)
Mais si je demande : « De quelle couleur est Ultra Sheen ? »,
un sourire apparaît,
s'ensuivent des histoires sur la salle de bains de la grand-mère.
Qui a besoin de turquoise quand on a Ultra Sheen ?
Qui a besoin de bleu sarcelle quand on a Ultra Sheen ?
Qui a besoin d'outremer quand on a...
(Public) Ultra Sheen.
(Rires)
C'est ainsi que j'ai dérivé ma palette.
J'ai demandé à des amis, à de la famille
et à des gens issus de milieux similaires au mien
des histoires et des souvenirs.
Les histoires n'étaient pas toujours heureuses
mais les couleurs résonnaient toujours plus que le produit lui-même.
J'ai mis ces théories en œuvre dans la rue.
« Ultra Sheen ».
« Pink Oil Moisturizer ».
Si vous venez de Chicago, « Harold's Chicken Shack ».
(Rires)
« Currency Exchange + Sage Passage ».
« Flamin' Red Hots ».
« Loose Squares » ...
et « Crown Royal Bag ».
J'ai peint des maisons devant être démolies sous peu
dans une zone très dénigrée appelée Englewood.
Nous avons réuni autant de peinture que pouvait contenir mon coffre,
j'ai appelé mes potes artistes les plus dignes de confiance,
mon merveilleux mari toujours à mes côtés,
et nous avons peint chaque centimètre des extérieurs
de façon monochromatique.
Je voulais comprendre les échelles comme je ne les avais jamais comprises.
Je voulais appliquer des couleurs aux plus grandes toiles imaginables...
des maisons.
Je faisais obstinément des allers-retours dans les rues familières où j'avais grandi
et je recoupais ces maisons avec les données du portail de la ville
pour m'assurer qu'elles avaient été marquées pour être démolies --
irrécupérables, laissées pour mortes.
Je voulais comprendre ce que c'était de laisser régner la couleur,
de faire confiance à mes instincts,
d'arrêter de demander la permission.
Pas de réunions avec les agents municipaux,
pas de soutien de la communauté,
laisser régner la couleur
dans mon désir de dépeindre différentes images des quartiers sud.
Il y a un contraste saisissant entre ces maisons et leurs homologues alignées.
Nous les peignions pour qu'elles ressortent
telles des pions de Monopoly
dans ces environnements.
Nous y allions tôt le dimanche matin
et continuions jusqu'à ne plus avoir de peinture ou que quelqu'un se plaigne.
« Hey, c'est vous qui avez fait ça ? »,
a demandé un conducteur alors que je prenais cette photo.
Moi, nerveusement :
« Oui ? »
Son expression a changé :
« Oh, j'ai cru que Prince allait venir ».
(Rires)
Il avait grandi dans ce quartier
alors vous pouvez imaginer, quand il est passé
et a vu l'une des dernières maisons changer mystérieusement de couleur
du jour au lendemain,
aucun sac Crown Royal n'était impliqué,
c'était un signal secret de Prince.
(Rires)
Même si ce quartier avait été presque entièrement effacé,
c'était l'idée que Prince puisse apparaître dans des lieux inattendus
et donner des concerts gratuits
dans des zones que l'industrie musicale et la société
avaient considérées comme n'ayant plus de valeur.
Pour lui,
l'idée que juste la vision de cette maison
suffisait à faire venir Prince
signifiait que cela était possible.
A ce moment-là,
ce petit bout d'Eggleston était devenu synonyme de royauté.
Ne serait-ce que brièvement,
le quartier d'Eric Bennett avait retrouvé sa valeur.
Nous avons échangé des histoires entre inconnus
sur le lycée auquel nous étions allés,
où nous avions grandi,
le propriétaire de la confiserie --
le fait d'être des enfants des quartiers sud.
Quand j'ai révélé
que ce projet n'avait absolument rien à voir avec Prince,
Eric a hoché la tête,
nous nous sommes séparés et alors qu'il partait,
il a dit : « Mais il pourrait quand même venir ! »
(Rires)
Il s'était entièrement approprié ce projet
et n'était pas prêt à y renoncer,
même face à moi, son auteure.
Pour moi, c'était une réussite.
J'aimerais pouvoir vous dire que ce projet a transformé le quartier
et tous les indices sur lesquels nous aimons nous reposer :
plus d'emplois, moins de crime, pas d'alcoolisme --
mais c'est plus gris que cela.
« La théorie de(s) couleur(s) » a catalysé de nouvelles conversations
sur la valeur d'être noir.
« La théorie de(s) couleur(s) » a indéniablement
rendu visibles les questions gênantes
que les institutions et gouvernements doivent se poser
quant à pourquoi ils font ce qu'ils font.
Elle pose des questions tout aussi difficiles
pour moi et mes homologues du quartier
sur nos systèmes de valeurs
et ce que doit être notre chemin vers une organisation collective.
La couleur m'a offert une liberté qui n'attendait pas de permission,
d'affirmation ou d'inclusion.
La couleur est une chose sur laquelle je pourrais régner.
Cela a été exprimé le mieux
par un des membres de notre quartier et de l'équipe de peintres
quand il a dit : « Cela n'a pas changé le quartier,
cela a changé la perception des gens sur ce qui est possible pour leur quartier »
à différentes échelles.
Un passant m'a demandé : « Pourquoi peignez-vous cette maison
quand vous savez que la ville va venir la détruire ? »
A l'époque, je n'avais aucune idée,
je savais juste que je devais faire quelque chose.
J'aurais tout donné pour mieux comprendre la couleur comme étant un support
et une façon inévitable dont je suis identifiée au sein de la société.
Si j'ai espoir de rendre le monde meilleur,
je dois aimer et tirer profit de comment je suis comprise
et c'est là que l'on trouve la valeur et la teinte.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)